I will tell you today about a connection
inspired by the great Primo levy I want
to first thank professor Stephanie Jed
my friend and a Glaser for organizing
this and of course our Dean our fearless
Dean professor Dillon Colette oh thank
you so much it's an honor to be here
celebrating what I who I consider to be
pretty much the most poly mathematical
if that's such a word scientist and an
inspiration to me as a scientist who
also hopes to inspire the public through
writing and that what he was able to do
in both literature and in science were
both extraordinary and I think that's
incredibly rare and I would like to you
know point out hopefully as an
inspiration his book was considered as
consider I think by the Royal
Institution to be the greatest popular
science book ever written and that was
before my book came out but so today I'm
gonna start with this quote that is
derived from Professor Peter B's a
wonderful autobiography where he calls
his family motto I believe was at astra
per aspera which means to the stars
through hardship and I like to say today
we're gonna go on the journey to the
Stars through the eyes of dust and this
is inspired by primo Levy's wonderful
story carbon in the periodic table and
on to point out this is the hundred and
fiftieth year as we just heard of the
periodic table some say it doesn't look
a day over 10 so it's got that going for
it it's had a little work done though in
order in the last 150 years and I want
to start you know because I'm faster I
want to start off with a little quiz
okay so you guys all ready for a quiz
didn't think there'd be a quiz in the
back you you litoris your students but
there's gonna be a quiz and it's a quiz
about my favorite subject the Nobel
Prize so here are three discoveries made
in the last hundred years that we're all
eligible to win the Nobel Prize and yet
only one of them did win the Nobel Prize
so I want to take a show of hands and
you must vote which of you think that
the the item labeled number one the RNA
molecule won the Nobel Prize it was
discovered in time to win the Nobel
Prize was eligible to win the Nobel
Prize nobody thinks item one okay brave
person number two
primo Levy's favorite subject the
periodic table which before you vote
note element 102 which name is nobelium
who thinks number two the periodic table
the reason we're here won the Nobel
Prize it was just called by the
professor before me the greatest
discovery of the human mind guys are not
really active today okay who thinks the
White House won the Nobel Prize okay and
then just for completeness who was
scared and terrified of raising your
hand in public raise your hand very high
up in the air so of course it is nothing
other than the lighthouse was won in
1912 by Gustav de lijn a Swedish man
which you want to have a higher chance
to win the Nobel Prize be born Swedish
and he won it for the invention of
automatic regulators for the use in
conjunction with gas regulators and
buoys now I know like many of you I got
here today using a gas powered
lighthouse and without it I wouldn't
even need my iPhone I just throw it away
if I had to do without the lighthouse
now of course that's just one of the
many controversies with the Nobel Prize
and I'm gonna not talk too much about
that except to say that many of my
colleagues and I have an affinity and an
addiction almost to winning the Nobel
Prize and and part of that is is
depicting this wonderful cartoon that
came out nature when my book was
published they showed this kind of image
of what it's like for some scientists
that looked to the heavens and they hope
to see this image of what I consider to
be a graven image and Idol this this
this entity Alfred Nobel who was of
course a chemist and he was an inventor
and I'm sure as we heard often times the
greatest authorities in physics we just
heard about five or ten from from the
previous speech we heard about five or
ten Nobel names dropped in them and
that's for good reason I think that it
is sort of the highest level of Fame and
authority that scientists can aspire to
but I discuss in my book there are some
downsides too I'm not gonna talk too
much about that I want to talk today
about something even older than the
periodic table even older than some of
the characters we'll be talking about
and that is in this story the story of
stars and really the prehistory so it's
said that the past is prologue right so
what happened before the carbon molecule
describes so tenderly lovingly
affectionately by Primo Levi in the
periodic
table well he describes mostly the the
life of a molecule of carbon as embedded
in a block of limestone but you know we
all come to into the universe without
really an understanding we enter in
matey arrays which Stephanie tells me
means in the middle of the story and so
what do you know about what came before
you well it comes from listening to
people as as the teen said who came
before you and learning the deep history
of what preceded you and many of us
professors especially have a fixation
that nothing really mattered before we
came into this world but in the case of
limestone I wanted to kind of lead up to
this picture of limestone and because
it's so beautifully described in Carvin
in the periodic table by Primo levy and
I want to just speak to the beauty in
the mystery that if you were around to
write you know the periodic table part
two that perhaps you'd include maybe
some of the prehistory of carbon in it
so I'm going to talk mostly about my
research and that is into the very
origin of the universe itself so the
event the only event perhaps for which
there is no prehistory if the universe
began with what we think of as the Big
Bang and actually that's more
controversial than it would have sounded
just a few years ago because there are
many theories that posit in fact there
are an infinite number of universes
before ours perhaps there's an infinite
number of universes concurrent to ours
currently and my research has direct
implication for those findings and I
want to talk to you about how we got
there and as described earlier by
Stephanie
there's some delightful and especially
important connections right here in UC
San Diego
so before October 2018 this was the last
woman to win a Nobel Prize in Physics
this is Professor Maria Kephart mayor
she understood better than anybody the
properties that made nuclei such as
carbon and other nuclei stable so in
order to have carbon in order for have
us to have the winemaker that the
limestone you need to have stability of
nuclear material and she worked out how
and why this is the case and of course
we named the the physics building is
named after her it's always cute I met
her son a few years before he passed
away when the US Post Office named a
stamp after Maryam Meir and he told me
on that that on the day she won the
Nobel Prize the San Diego union-tribune
I forget what it was called
Union or the Tribune or whatever it had
a headline and it said La Jolla
housewife wins Nobel Prize and I have a
funny thing because in this the
thankfully as I said Donna Strickland
won the Nobel Prize in 2018 but as great
as that is and as a wonderful it is to
have women winning Nobel prizes they
would have to only award it to women for
the next 75 years in order to achieve
parity between men and women so that's
just a side note I'm not going to talk
too much about that I want to focus on
another chemist or famous is actually a
nuclear chemist nuclear physicist Harold
Urey who discovered a deuterium before
he came to UCSD but for which we have
named our chemistry department after
after Harold Urey he did many other
things I'm sure we'll hear about in
terms of the chemistry of life which is
really quite astounding and resonate to
this very day and connect to this quest
that human beings have unique to
humanity to wanna understand where we
came from we have you know this this
affinity to understand where did the
universe come from where did life come
from will here next and then where did
consciousness come from how does
consciousness emerge those are the three
great big bang's
as I call them and and the desire to
understand that would be impossible
without the discoveries maria mayer and
harold urey
so he discovered how deuterium takes
place in nuclear fusion how that began
the process of the formation of the very
first stars in the universe that later
shed their gave their lives to produce
the material for the second generation
of stars and that was depicted and
described very very in great depth by
professor Margaret Burbidge and I'll
describe her in a minute and her protege
Vera Rubin who is the discoverer of Dark
Matter neither one of these women
unfortunately were rewarded with Nobel
Prizes although they certainly deserved
it and I want to talk to these two women
I call them the queens of the dark so
you might get the impression from
looking at these pictures so Margit
Berbers this is a picture taken by Ansel
Adams and the previous picture of Harold
Urey was taken by Ansel Adams on campus
here quite one quite wonderful it's a
little hard to see but in both cases
they're sitting there in front of
microscopes now I think it's weird I've
never seen an astronomer male or female
look into a microscope okay I've never
seen it before in my life but apparently
this is the way they like to be depicted
this picture on the right i got from the
carnegie institutions of law
and Margaret Burbidge took and Jeff
Brevard she was also a colleague of mine
he has since passed away
Margaret Burbage is alive and well and
about a hundred years old and she she
helped to reveal the process by which
stars that are the second generation of
entities in the universe that produced
nuclear fusion how they are the ones
responsible for producing the carbon
that would eventually make its way into
limestone and eventually make its way
into the drunkard or the the the person
who drinks the great the wine in the
story today we carry on this tradition
of great knowledge about stellar
astrophysics Mike Norman's group has put
an entire universe in a box in a
computer here at the san diego
supercomputer center what he does is he
simulates under gravity and chemical
forces and attraction throughout plasma
that was predominant in the early
universe the very first generations of
stars which then later make the second
generations of stars and through work
with a very famous astronomer Fred Hoyle
and Jeff Burbidge and Margot burbage
they were able to publish their famous
paper which is now known by the initials
margaret beverages being first be bfh
one of the landmark papers in all of
physics 70 years old and that describes
how these stars could undergo what
really can only be thought of to be a
miracle which greatly troubled Fred
Hoyle Fred Hoyle came up with the name
Big Bang I'm not going to tell you what
it means because it was a pejorative to
British speaking people for English
speakers because there's some youth in
the audience and I don't to corrupt you
but it was an insult to the theory that
posited the universe came X Neil EO in
the Big Bang he was deeply atheistic and
he felt that this was an abomination
this theory and he gave it this name
unfortunately for him it stuck but
before he did that he can't come up with
an explanation I'm gonna use what we now
would consider to be an anthropic
argument an argument from based on the
existence of us that would give
information about how the early universe
must have behaved or in this case how
stars behave and he said well we're
mostly made of carbon this famous not
just famous in the essay by by Primo
levy but we're mostly made of carbon
carbon has to exist and yet it's
extremely difficult to get the main
players involved which are namely really
three helium nuclei you see these these
two helium nuclei come together they
give off a gamma ray which is just a
fancy name for
a high-energy particle of light and then
they create the state of beryllium now
you may not know anything about
chemistry and hopefully for my sake you
don't because I don't know much about
chemistry either but but helium is made
of two protons and two neutrons when two
positively charged nted neutrons are on
charger neutral how do you get two
positively charged things to come
together in the first place and then how
do you get four of them to come together
and stick together well the answer was
it required a miracle a state known as a
resonance that Boyle worked out from
from the assumption that life must exist
in such a way that carbon needs to be
able to form by this process this
process the intermediate state of
beryllium eight lasts for something you
chemists will correct me I'm sure
something like a trillionth of a
millisecond so at last infinitely long
amount of time but eventually this this
carbon and I say miracles don't last
long because eventually the star builds
up an onion like skeleton structure
until it makes iron Fe chemical symbol
Fe when it makes iron it no longer gives
off those photons to to keep the
pressure up to resist the gravitational
pull of the shells that it made earlier
and when that happens a cataclysmic
explosion takes place depicted here
this is a star exploding after it
reaches that state where it's making
iron and no longer and supports
gravitational collapse when it does that
it feeds the local area of our galaxy
with the material of which we're
comprised namely carbon iron etc and
that's why if you've ever held a
meteorite and I'll I'll compliment
Andy's show-and-tell with some
meteorites up here you can come up and
fondle the meteorites you'll find
they're very heavy and they're very
magnetic like iron that's because they
are belched out from the innards of this
star called a type 2 supernova so there
is this lovely sleep-inducing animation
music and so these bodies that are
ejected from the star eventually
congealed to make the earth and some of
the iron that was inside of that nuclear
of the of the center of that star is now
flowing through your veins so it's
literally flowing through the hemoglobin
in your body in your blood and so
literally as it said you have star stuff
flowing through you and it's true we
wouldn't be here without that wonderful
star stuff here's a picture of it and
some excerpts from the quote by Primo
levy from carbon this is our character
which is a carbon molecule lives for
lies for hundreds of millions of years
bound to three atoms of oxygen and one
of calcium this is calcium carbonate
chalk is another I don't know we have
chalk should have it here our atom of
carbon enters the leaf eventually
collides with innumerable
but here are useless molecules of
nitrogen oxygen to make chlorophyll so
it's astonishing the interconnectedness
between the earliest entities in the
universe II nuclei of helium and
hydrogen and then how they came to enter
into a star that then itself exploded
then it congealed and that it's
materials got into the earth and
eventually some of that carbon was in
the chlorophyll molecule and eventually
some of it was in limestone and
eventually some of it was in a grape and
now I want to take us fast forward from
you know thirteen billion years ago
perhaps to a hundred years ago 1919
primo Levy was born this connection down
here it says now our atom is inserted it
is part of a structure in an
architectural sense it has become
related and tied to the five companion
so identical with it that only the
fiction of the story permits me to
distinguish them and that's showing this
interconnectedness between carbon and
the other elements that make up life
these are all belts
from stars and these are cutting-edge
results from spectroscopy the likes of
which are done here by my colleagues
such as Alison Cole and Shelly Wright
and Quinn Kona [ __ ] and others that do
incredible work on the spectroscopy the
chemical fingerprints of life found in
the stars
and made me think of this quote by a
fellow Italian the Sun with all those
planets revolving around it and depended
on it can still ripen a bunch of grapes
as if it had nothing else in the
universe to do now you guys have more to
do and I have more to do so I want to
just fast forward now from 13 billion
years so about 410 years ago when
Galileo used this device a telescope a
simple device which he had found by way
of the oldest academic tradition
possible
aka plagiarism so he had discovered this
advice he had only heard about it that
it was invented by a Dutchman
and just upon hearing about it this
brilliant mind the greatest mind in my
in my opinion in in scientific history
he invented a new type of telescope that
was much more powerful and he used other
innovations to make it more useful to
the astronomer and so he became the
first astronomer I call him the biblical
bludgeon because of the famous episodes
that took place afterwards and I won't
get into too much detail about but you
can go visit this telescope there's one
lens that survives or you can view this
one which I got on Amazon for 1995 which
is almost the exact same size and with
this tiny little device Galileo was able
like Archimedes said to use as a lever
to move the entire earth displacing it
from the center of the universe for the
position and had enjoyed since antiquity
to just another planet amidst other
planets known at that time so he was a
very successful self-published author he
published the Siderius none see as soon
after this and in the Siderius nuncius
which is written in latin for a reason I
bring up that'll be important in just a
second he wrote this in Latin and he
depicted over the course of several
nights in January of 1910 8 sorry 1610
he depicted the images of planets and
but not only the planets themselves and
how they appeared through the telescope
but also these strange stars which he
sycophantic ly named after his patron
which were the medici families he called
these stars which we now know as the
Galilean moons
he realized he was seeing a solar system
on edge and it was a brilliant
visualization a thought experiment he
placed himself above the plane of the
massive planet Jupiter it's just truly
brilliant priests aging by four hundred
years the same types of techniques that
Einstein would later employ the great
success and so what Severus nuncius
assured in was the notion with physical
evidence obtained through a telescopic
device a scientific piece of apparatus
you could change the notions of
philosophy and even of theology and for
a while things went well until he made
what I consider his greatest blunder I'm
not gonna get into great detail about it
and that was to observe the the constant
the mass tourism called Subaru if you're
Japanese or the Pleiades or Seven
Sisters if you're not and he depicted
them with an artist touch very beautiful
very few of these actually original
copies of the Siderius nuncius that harm
forgeries still exist they go for about
a million dollars and when he sat down
here is quite beautiful this is what was
observed by us is the nature of our
matter of the Milky Way itself and he's
saying for the first time with the aid
of the spyglass I have revealed the
nature of the entire universe a little
bit of hubris but you know he was a
professor and and I made him quite
famous and nowadays we know that visible
certainty is not the greatest guide to
being a scientist so it's actually it
goes by another name now called called
confirmation bias but I think it's kind
of cute when I you know I'm blessed to
have children I can I can I can sing the
famous lullabies too and they can even
squeak it out on their violins to great
pain and discomfort but they'll play a
twinkle twinkle little star and it says
at the bottom of twinkles it says like a
diamond in the sky right well this
nebula surrounding the Pleiades that
Galileo first saw through a telescope a
human being ever to see is actually made
of some isotopes of pure carbon our
character from the story by Prima
leaving so there's stars just pure
carbon there's diamonds in the sky and
that is actually correct
so immediately afterwards Galileo had
some success so the first thing that
happened was he proved as many
inventions are used for that had great
military advantage because with the
telescope what does it mean it means you
can see things at great distance so he
proved you could see things such as
ships coming in on
Venetian Lagoon and you could remove a
day's worth of time from spotting them
that means you had a day which is like
spotting the stealth bomber before it
even takes off nowadays and it with it
you could see such things that the human
I couldn't see by itself I can see you
falling asleep in the back please wake
up
and so he immediately transferred this
and leveraged this into the two things
that every professor wants instantaneous
tenure okay that was great
and his Dean doubled his start-up
funding so keep that in mind if you want
to discover and become you know
instantly tenured and munificent lee
remunerated but things didn't you know
continue that long at first he became
quite famous I don't believe he ever
left Italy I believe that's the case but
he actually became quite famous not as
famous as this person but it's sue in
this position in Pisa put him under the
influence of the Roman Catholic Church
and he didn't abide by Pope Urban who
later became his friend and was his
friend actually there's a fiction that
the Pope the church was very anti
science and they hate it they actually
let him keep writing as long as he
didn't write in Italian because we know
we read in Italian things get very
tricky right now I'm just kidding no you
you're all wonderful it ready but look
here this is an Italian right I don't
know the difference being Italian the
Latin but Dean you can tell us and Andy
can tell us this is actually an Italian
that was the language of the masses it
would be like the difference between us
trying to read Latin nowadays or you
know giving it to my kids in the you
know in emojis everybody understood
Italian at this time this was a big
boo-boo because the Pope had firt
allowed him to keep talking about it but
he couldn't teach it which sounds weird
but teaching meant publishing in an
Italian you couldn't but put it on
YouTube right so this was the main way
of communicating in lecturing and Cara
and his proximity to the church was
actually ended up being his downfall
so like some of us he maybe shouldn't
have accepted that tenured position but
what it did is uh sure in the Copernican
model of the universe which is that the
Sun is the center of the universe which
itself is incorrect and that's the
beauty of science another famous great
science fiction author I learned just
now from Andy that that primo wrote a
lot of science fiction I didn't know
that
isaac asimov after whom one of my sons
his name is a was a wonderful scientist
and science fiction author and he said
something like the following he said if
you think that the earth is the center
of the universe you're wrong and if you
think that the Sun is the center of the
universe you're wrong but if you think
you're wrong in exactly the same way
then you're no scientist
meaning that Sciences props process is
meant to disprove itself and not to be
succumbed to things like authority bias
or confirmation bias
it's the self-correcting nature that
Richard Feynman talked about that you
mentioned that is the essence of what it
means to be a good scientist and that
means failure often times it means
failure so for him he had great deal of
failure after this he had great success
but he was in prison for the last nine
years of his life we actually had a
workshop in his villa Yoga olio and
outside of the University of Florence
phenomenal place to have a workshop
except you wanna if you ever want to
feel really tall go there because all
the doors are about like this tall so
you bump your head up there and so
Galileo assured in a view of the world
that I depict and discuss in the book
really out to the realm of the nebula
the nebula within our own galaxy I want
to fast forward another great leap in
time back to 400 years forward when we
came to invent the bicep telescope the
reason we invented the bicep telescope
is because we wanted to understand what
the beginning of time itself was
actually like not the first 400 million
years not the first billion first
million years not the first second not
the first millisecond the first
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second as close as there
is a nature where you could
fundamentally say that time is changing
if you go back to the beginning of time
time doesn't exist so how do you measure
the discretization of time well the
smallest increment of time is known as
the Planck time we wanted to go back as
close as we could to that time and we
did so we thought by inventing this
telescope called bicep I'm not gonna get
into great detail about it suffice it to
say it's a refracting telescope that
uses lenses that are transparent to
microwaves which look like this you
wouldn't think this is transparent to
microwaves but it is and it focuses
light not onto Galileo's retina as this
device did but on top of these
superconducting detectors very similar
to devices we make here at UC San Diego
right
the way in the cleanroom down the hall
and the reason for this is we want to
understand the progression from today
where we see galaxies back to the
earliest light in the universe called
the Cosmic Microwave Background back to
the earliest possible epoch in time
called inflation and that was the
subject of and we claim that we did it I
won't get into great detail here I don't
have much more time but we claimed in
March 17 2014 that we discovered the
earliest evidence for matter and energy
in our universe the detection of what's
called the swirling twisting type of
polarization and the experiment was
known as bicep2 for reasons that get
into in the book but I won't here and we
announced it to great fanfare so it was
on every newspaper it was on CNN shown
here and that we had discovered the
earliest possible evidence for the
origin of the universe this is
astounding discovery and and people
covered it and of course is my favorite
favorite headline about this discovery
in the onion a very great and well-known
renowned scientific journal where they
convened a panel of top physicists and
R&B singers okay so they had a Reetha
Franklin the late great Aretha Franklin
there's Lionel Richie I believe over
there and they talked about whether or
not it's possible to give you my heart
forever okay so it's again this
fascination with the early universe a
real headline but of course as they say
ashes to ashes dust to dust and not all
that is meant to be discovered can be
discovered and in our case we actually
made a misidentification and that we
discovered instead of the first wispy
imprints of the might of the of the
origin of our universe instead we
discovered the knots of wispy imprints
of galactic schmutz schmutz not on our
lens cap but floating through the galaxy
the same nebula that gave Galileo this
impression that he understood the nature
of matter and energy in the universe
mostly made of carbon and iron and other
things belched out from these type Q
super so instead of seeing the universe
like this where we peer out from earth
pristine view of the of the cosmos and
its infant state instead we know that
the early universe and even our galaxy
looks a lot like Los Angeles okay it's
polluted with smog and schmutz and we
have to look through it
we have to now design a better
experiment to do what bicep could not do
and its original in its original case
and along with our chances of
discovering the earliest moment in the
universe we also got our chances of
winning Nobel Prizes blown away but I
think this quote from primo at the
bottom says we are here for this to make
mistakes and to correct ourselves I
think it's a beautiful sentiment I think
that scientists should know that and of
course a corollary to this you have to
admit when you're wrong and that in
order to have this this humility in
order to move on without humiliation you
must be honest with yourself in the way
that fineman's as we heard described so
a lot of this in my case alone at least
I know I was driven by desire to win the
Nobel Prize and I wanted some peak about
Alfred Nobel because he was a chemist
and he died only about 20 years before
primo levy was born and Waite was
actually the the endowment of his will
took place there series of events I
described but really it was a it was a
form of public relations he want to
redeem the Nobel name that have been
associated with death and devastation
for the better part of the 19th century
so to improve upon bicep we had to build
a better experiment we know we have to
now we're in the midst of constructing
the Simon's Observatory we are the lead
institution I'm the privileged to be the
director of this of this wonderful
experiment and what is it well it's a
giant vacuum cleaner in space that can
actually suck up the dust okay so it's
the yes it's 150th anniversary of cream
of the periodic table hundredth
anniversary of primo levy 40th
anniversary for us parents of the
Dustbuster I mean who this should win a
Nobel Prize
so no seriously what is the Simon's
Observatory it's a set of telescopes
located in the Atacama Desert of
northern Chile you can view it we're
setting up a kind of an alumni tour of
it next year hopefully maybe I'll even
get professor Viterbi to come down
because inside of it we use the Viterbi
algorithm in some of our detectors we
have a hundred thousand detectors nearly
and they're going to be sampled at a
rate that is so high that we couldn't
without this applying of Iturbi
algorithm basically CDMA version of CD
we could not do the experiment as we're
intending so this will get first light
as we call it in about two and a half
years and as I said if you can make it
there and you get a doctor's note you
come and visit us I want to conclude
with a short poem by Carl Sagan that
emphasizes the interconnectedness that
astounds me even to this day he says in
this famous pion to dust as I call it
the the the call the pale blue top he
says we succeeded in taking this picture
what is this picture it's a selfie of
Earth taken by Voyager one before many
of you students were even born in 1990
on Valentine's Day 1990 he commanded the
Voyager 1 satellite from beyond the
orbit of Saturn to take a picture of the
earth and you could see it there right
now you can't even see there's a circle
around it so a single pixel and he goes
through in a very poetic fashion he
describes how all the wars we fought for
conquest and territory and ten pop
didn't dictators that were fighting for
a fraction of what we call a pixel it's
just astonishing in that way and he says
you see it that's a dot that dot is here
it's home it's us every saint and sinner
in the history of our species lived
there on a mote of dust suspended in a
sunbeam a lot of sort of almost stoic
like beauty in that statement so I like
to say that you know I'm quoting the
Bible you know Bible says ashes to ashes
dust to dust what does it mean well the
word Adam in Hebrew I'm sure professor
glacier can correct me means Earth and
it means that God formed according to
this biblical tradition you can believe
it or not I don't care but he formed
Adam which means dirt and earth so your
form from Earth and what's your final
resting place you turn back into dust so
what do we have in life
we just have these two moments this
moment between these two periods of dust
and our job is to maximize that with
humility and love and intention and I
think no person better summarized that
kind of desire than Primo Levi and so
it's an honor to be here
I do have books up here for the students
and thank you very much
you
[Applause]
you